the daily wire has a new movie coming
out we filmed this movie about 6 months
ago and I can't believe how quickly the
editors were able to put it together
Jeremy sent me the script whenever it
was 7even eight months ago and I read it
and I instantly said I said hey man this
is a masterpiece this this screenplay is
a
masterpiece it's just so out there
people the libs are going to lose their
minds over this movie I said no this has
never been done I mean this reminds me
of like all those great comedies of the
mid 2000s that you don't see anymore
because everyone's so offended by
everything and and no studio will put it
out and he said exactly we're the only
people who can put it out so we got to
put it out so we did this movie you'll
see some familiar faces in there it's
it's a masterp I don't know how else to
put it it's a masterpiece all of you
will get to see it at the Live premiere
event exclusively on dailywire plus
Friday night 8:00 p.m. Eastern join
dailywire plus get 50 bucks off your new
membership right now